hello my name is David Brandon I'm the
writer director of goodbye promise hi my
name is Gregor Collins and I am the lead
actor and producer of goodbye promise
hey everyone I'm Karen warden I'm one of
the producers and actors on good luck
promised we'd really like to show you
this film and we'd like to tell you our
story but first let's show you the
trailer
evernote here seven years when I came
out here you know that I was so wide I
wanted it so badly I was so passionate
I've worked hard it just has paid off so
I'm taking off
I just wanted to let you know that I've
always believed
did you ever wonder before this point
like what if you can quit and you can
walk back and you can see I gave it my
all I gave it my seven years but the
passion will still be down there so deep
and you'll feel it every day and you
wonder why I don't walk away 17 years
plus one day I could have had it
definitely he definitely was not
supposed to be like this
if there's anything inside you that
still feels that sanely that got you
come out here to be an actor in the
first place then you have to stick with
it
if I said I'm staying in LA
what you say
and welcome back thanks for watching our
trailer we were feeling a lot of the
feelings that Matt the main character
feels about having a career in
entertainment and whether you keep going
whether you give up you've invested a
lot of time in it a lot of emotion and
you also know that probably the
alternative isn't really what's going to
fulfill you so we took those feelings
and we put them in a project the reason
why I made good by promise is because
over 12 years ago i came on your Los
Angeles pursuing this Hollywood ring you
know and here i am to this day and and
I've put in how you know more you know
so many of my waking hours so much of my
waking energy as I sort of gone into
this dream that I had and and and I'm
still not there yet you know believe me
I'm still not there yet this is a film
that was so authentic to our personal
lives and
we really just wanted to pinch ourselves
and to see if our own dreams and our own
hopes and our own lives work or even
worth fighting for and worth
living in all right just to make it
really really clear is we are using any
Go Go as a way to distribute this film
[ __ ] I'm surprised I really am people
are really people people have felt
something for it and that actually I
have a friend that I've never seen cry
before and he walked out of the theater
he had tears in his eyes and that was
really weird I'd every I didn't even
know he had tear ducts be honest but he
had tears in his eyes and he took me and
he brought me a beer and we talked for
two hours so long as we've ever talked
about how he was affected by it and he's
not even an actor and he he's like he
works in corporate and you could kind of
see it in their eyes they were like it
affected them and I think that seeing
that it's Universal to question
ourselves and want to give up on
something when it isn't working is is
this an interesting thing just to see we
all struggle with it and then maybe from
there we can learn to move through it if
we know that we're not alone in that and
it's not like oh well other people is
just have it all figured out I'm the
only one that like can't figure it out I
mean how often have you heard of an
independent film that that's maybe
playing the film festivals it's like oh
wow that sounds really nice but I would
like to see that film and yeah then the
film's not available you know and
there's nowhere to see it and then a few
months go by and now you've forgotten
about it and you're probably never going
to see that film again you know we
wanted to try to think of a way where we
could take our little film and just make
it so that when we finally did release
it it was available to anyone and
everyone that was interested in seeing
it so the million-dollar question is can
we think of a better way to release this
film and the answer is ding ding ding
nope it's IndieGoGo what would be the
best way to release this film with some
of the platforms that already exist and
and we believe we've identified
that the best way for us to release our
film am I excited to release this film
on IndieGoGo I am I love Annie go go
they have great personalized customer
service I'm have really cool projects
featured on their site this is a new way
of doing this online release thing is
you can't hide the numbers so we have to
be transparent there's no way it's going
to be seen on IndieGoGo but it'll be
nice because uh because we do it I do
everything myself anyway and this is
natural for me I quickly I realized
after years in Hollywood that no one was
going to hand me anything and no one was
gonna no one was going to have anything
on a silver platter and so I have to do
it myself so this just goes along with
the territory and and it's there's no
pressure because it's not like we're
gonna make millions of dollars of this I
mean that's not the plan of course we
want millions of people to see it we
want to put our film in the best
possible position so that for anyone
that really enjoys it for anyone that
wants to share the film they have that
opportunity to share it you know we want
this whole thing to be to be seamless to
be frictionless and it's super simple
we're offering it for one dollar for the
first hundred backers and then after
that will be two dollars the film is
totally done and it's ready to be seen
and it's very simple you just go to the
side on you you pledge your dollar
amount and then you go to the update
section click on update and we have the
film embedded and it's ready to be
viewed you can watch the films right
there the reason why we made this a
million-dollar goal is because we want
this thing to be exciting you know that
I mean this is the release of our film
we wanted to be exciting for us we want
it to be exciting for you and we want to
chase that that impossible dream you
know we want to get up every day and
and have a reason to be excited about
something you know it's a go act or
something so that that's what that's all
about this is where we part ways enjoy
the film and if it really spoke to you
then hit me up on Twitter or Facebook
it's there's a lot of moments of levity
there's there's some really funny
moments and it sets I don't want it to
seem like it's such a tearjerker you'll
you'll probably laugh and you're
probably crying lastly if goodbye
promise strikes a chord with you please
share it